big man what's going on what's up how's
your evening
pretty [ __ ] good and it's a lot
better now that i'm hearing that sultry
voice what are you up to
oh well i'm already the tears are
already coming on my eyes well i had a
full day of chess
some pogchamps commentary tons of stuff
and uh could not think of a better way
to round it off
in my devious evil mind i had designed
or thought of an activity that i think
might be interesting something new
uh that we might do among other things
today so
i'll save that as a pr as a surprise and
explain that later once
well i don't know if you'll love this
one because it involves playing fast and
i know that's not
something that you enjoy greatly
[Music]
so um one thing that i wanted to do
independently of that is actually play
another odds game and work a little bit
more on your technique
okay yeah i'm down food everybody why
don't we jump in the pool
first for like a warm-up game or two
okay i'm gonna take a quick tinkle
i played an absolutely monstrous game
earlier though i haven't played much
chess since our last lesson
but today i made a dude show me his
[ __ ] like i went nuts so you should
pull up my life
i need to look at that yeah you're going
to very last game
yeah you might want to make sure your
stream's not on right now because you
will probably cream yourself it is nuts
what i did to that poor man
i'll go on starting soon if you go into
live streams before you
take a piss i'll be able to look at it
because i can find you and then look at
yeah i just i'm in
you should find it now i when you come
back i might have to come to the
bathroom to clean up so i'm just warning
you
okay so that's good i'm excited for this
all right all right give me two seconds
i'll be right back take care as long as
you need
okay so this is very very promising
i like to hear that kind of excitement
so let's see
so it was a philidor knight c3 oh he
could have made legals
maybe he could have done legals mate he
could have done
legals okay we gotta talk about this
charlie could have done legals mate
this is legals mate now i'm gonna have a
little surprise for him when he's back
okay so he goes here oh knight b6
now this is some improvement if i've
ever seen a knight b6
jesus ryan you could beat him with with
definitely more than night outs
don't underestimate here so this is
disgusting knight b6
is called improvement
oh my land i mean this guy had
no chance if charlie played every game
like that
he'd be like 1300 okay so what we're
gonna do today i i think you guys will
enjoy this activity and so
well i don't think charlie will enjoy it
is
to work very specifically on his speed
and confidence he has to get faster
regardless of everything else that's one
of the key priorities
and i will admit to you guys that i
thought for a very long time about how
to actually work on that other than to
make him play blitz and i think i have
an interesting method
that involves me uh so
you know keep an open mind folks keep an
open mind folks i'll explain what that
method will entail
um that is a crazy game i'm i'm just
he's come very far knight b6
it's the only correct discovery because
knight c7 check
it it's the only correct this move is
not correct because queen takes
simultaneously guarding the pawn
simultaneously guarding the pawn so
knight v6 is the only correct discovery
this might be one of his best moves
other than that movie played a couple of
lessons ago
okay so i'm proud but legals but legals
mate
but legals mate he's gotta know about
legals mate all right i'm back you [ __ ]
you talking [ __ ]
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa you watch
your frickin mouth now now
i have news for you i'm gonna give you
an a minus for this game
and there's only one reason i'm not
giving you an a plus the move knight b6
that was the closest i came to having to
change from shorts to jeans
can i invite you to an analysis board
really quickly because i have to show
you this yeah
well i also want my stream to see this
because this i went straight primal on
this poor guy
now i want to as i invite you to the
analysis board
other than what i'm about to show you
was perfect the move knight d6 move
seven
the only move that wins on the spot
there was a guy in the 18th century
um french guy played chess um
you know never spent a day in jail
because his last name was legal
i believe it's pronounced well i have no
idea how it's pronounced
and uh i want you to just keep this guy
in your mind he's a very dashing
gentleman i know him from the trap that
i used to like to run the legals trap
the legal strap huh well let me tell you
something about the legal strap
because in this position you could have
freaking legal corrupted that's the one
and i want you to tell me how
oh and i'm actually like
just the fact that it existed is pretty
darn cool yeah well i mean it's the same
setup as always right i'm taking here
he's taking here and then that's
immediately game
then we come here he only has this and
that's game
exactly takes and if he takes the knight
then what do you do
then i'm taking the bishop right so he
probably wouldn't have fell into the
mate but
the move that is freaking amazing and
okay
the one piece of praise i'm gonna you
know the one praise per lesson
um everyone should know knight b6
freaking only move
that wins the game and i like that you
didn't put it on c7 because the queen
captures
simultaneously but you have to distract
the clip
and everything else you did was i mean
just vacuumed up literally freaking
every piece
show that in slow motion right here this
is one of those real lovely games i was
so proud of this one
i mean this is like you did your
freaking breakfast lunch and dinner so
you take here
takes the bishop now you don't take the
knight right that would be
tempting but much better is what you did
to take the pawn forking the king and
the rook
queen takes h8 and to add insult to
injury he can't even move his
freaking knight because his rook is
spent that's right
poor's that guy was having a freaking
bat and d3 patient
not taking the knight because then he
takes the pawn with check causing
unpleasantness to your king
so and now you take the knight
not forgetting about development and
then spotting the fork i mean
damn pretty solid pretty darn
i i thought you'd like that one that
game right there i was playing out of my
[ __ ] mind
i do and i think that after what we do
today which is to build up that speed
and confidence i think you're capable of
playing more of these games
so i'm you know i don't i don't like to
use the word proud because a russian
coach is not supposed to say that right
um but
i'm that's pretty darn good so
you did make me happy i was having a
good day but now i'm having a better day
so now let's reproduce that in in the
pool
all right let's hop in there i'm ready
to just go wild again
oh you're gonna [ __ ] you're good
you're just gonna
oh crap i immediately uh misclicked
i actually play that move that's called
the perk defense
or pierce there is a name for there is a
name for everything under god's blue sky
and chess
as crappy as it might be
so how does this line go do you now play
e5 on the next well you prepare it you
prepare the movie five
um and all of your development from this
point on should be geared
toward preparing the push of the e pawn
right you can't play e5
immediately he's got three defenders on
the square you've got two attackers
so think about your dark squared bishop
where can you develop it such that it's
conducive to preparing
um yeah
and yeah this is essentially a version
of sort of the king's indian defense
which i've played my whole life
very nice okay so he's playing the
london system can you play e5 here
let's see i have what
do i yeah i come out on top of this
right by push exactly you can do it now
he's probably gonna move his bishop back
to g3 would be my guess um
well actually no he he takes first okay
okay so i take back with pawn now this
knight on g8 you want to be careful
about where you develop it you do not
want to intercept
your bishop's control over your e5 pawn
so
you want to put it on a square so that
it doesn't impede the control of that
pawn
yes i'm just going e7 right exactly yeah
perfect
yeah this type of opening you know
unbalances the position
okay this should be five now is he
actually threatening to take the knight
on c6 is that something you have to
reckon annoying is that something
annoying yeah
are you sure but look at your knight on
e7 part of the benefit of connecting
your knights like that
is that one can replace this take it
back so i see it
in reality you don't actually have to do
anything especially you can just
continue developing
okay so should i just castle then yeah
i'm just gonna definitely get out of the
pin right
well that doesn't really work right so
do it so in this position is it better
to take with the bishop or the knight
here well which piece would you
rather like keep on the board like you
think about your bishop is it
is it important to the safety of your
king now that you've encountered it
yes yes so you want to take with the
knight when you fianchetto the bishop
the
drawback of a fianchetto is that you
weaken the squares around the theme gato
which means that trading that bishop all
things held if would still be winning of
course but
um you know you want to develop an
emotional attachment to that bishop as i
have
oh of course definitely shed some tears
when it's been lost before okay
so i want to see how you convert an
advantage what comes to mind
uh well there's g4 for my lights tile
bishop but it's kind of worthless he
just pushes up a pawn anyway it's not
the greatest so i
i don't think that would be worth like
worth doing so where would you
put it i was looking at
f5 and maybe cutting off a long castle
if you choose to do that
that's fine yeah reasonable move not the
best thing you can do but it is fine
um and after the game we'll talk about
this is actually a pretty instructive
moment
okay when you're up a piece there's many
things you can do
okay
so now you have to sort of try to
perceive what the holes are in his
position what are the weak squares
that you can maneuver your pieces to or
even put the pieces on immediately
so i was looking at d3 for my knight
which delivers a check
and he'd have to move the king so he
loses his castling rights
and if he takes that knight with a
bishop what piece is the bishop replay
what piece d
does replaces the knight i want to
replace it with the queen
exactly stopping him from castling and
that's just going to be devastating
notice that you do
potentially lose your c7 pawn but this
is the posit kind of position where
nobody gives
two flying shits about pawns i mean
you're going for the
remember okay exactly so i told you a
while ago there's two ways to convert an
advantage
going for mate or simplifying you've
chosen the first
and in order to go for mate you need to
look very closely at how you can use the
avenues available to you
in order to just infiltrate so you have
a very good devastating move here
i was looking at bringing a rook to d8
and then just punching in like that but
i don't think that's probably going to
be the best move right idea but not the
best execution look at his queen on b7
you can
punch the rook in as you say by force
and onto a much more effective square
uh b2 so i put it on b exactly yep
and he can take on c7 he can take it
sure enough i mean it doesn't matter
you're taking on b2 and check winning
him
yeah and he does he can't even move his
queen away to try to trade queens he has
to allow either give up his queen or
allow rook takes b2
so you see how effective these
unbalancing openings can actually be
because people just aren't familiar with
the types of positions that arise
yeah and this guy definitely sucked a
fat dick a little early he just didn't
he just couldn't keep up with the
intensity man
it's the indian defenses that's what
they're what the defense is where you
play g6 the openings that
you feed keto your bishop early like
this against c4 king's indian defense
old indian defense i've literally played
them my whole life
they're really awesome so
don't [ __ ] whatever you trash me
grandmaster title okay you don't touch
the king's indian or i'm hanging up
okay well keep that in mind
i know you were planning to do that so
well i mean you know me i love to [ __ ]
all over
kings you woke up this morning you were
like damn this king's indian
oh man this is just a pleasure look at
your pieces
every piece the queen the rook and he's
probably going to defend the night with
his rook if i
know lego rooster uh it's either that or
he resigns
i think he's going to do that and when
you're attacking like this it's
all about bringing pieces into the
attack okay so you need to look at all
each literally each one of your pieces
ask yourself can you bring it into the
attack
and if there are multiple pieces you can
bring to the attack which one is most
effective
so what comes to mind the one i looked
at immediately that at least gets in
there with some tempo
was bringing the bishop to take on b3
exactly that's
the most accurate so really the only
instructive moment here where
i have really anything to say is um and
we'll look at that as uh
move 10 bishop f5 so
wow now
this technique was good the question is
are you going to beat me with queen nuts
this time
mm-hmm how are you feeling if i can i'm
feeling good last time we had a lesson i
beat you on a puzzle
i beat you to finishing a puzzle i had a
dead a good checkmating idea you didn't
see i don't know
i might just be better better than the
great daniel naraditsky
i believe it's funny because yesterday i
was doing a lesson with uh hafu
uh it was a streamer in pogchamps too
and we were doing
a couple puzzles and uh she wanted to do
sort of like a
a gm level puzzle um you know like a
puzzle in 2700
rating category and actually i got it
wrong and
i think like i was like everybody was
shocked but
when they're hard you know there are
puzzles that i do on a regular basis
that
are challenging for me well yeah yeah i
mean that's the point of puzzles right
exactly it has to be right at the limit
okay i think this guy is reconsidering
some of his like life choices
i don't know yeah this has been pretty
rough man so the exercise that we are
going to do and
obviously pending your agreement you i'm
not forcing you
into it um let me kind of while he's
thinking
uh let me explain what it will be so
i didn't want you just to play sort of
bullet right one minute chess like i
could do that but i wanted to make it
sort of more constructive than that
um although at some point if you really
are serious about getting faster that is
a good idea believe it or not
that's like the best prescription in the
world like some bullet
yeah unfortunately i imagine but what
we're gonna do is we are going to play a
version of odds games you against me
where you basically have one minute at
the start of the game and we can adjust
as necessary to win a position
but you have basically a queen and two
rooks extra
so you have an overwhelming material
advantage but the catch is
you have only a minute to win and
because i can't challenge you from a
position that's going to be
logistically a little tough but i've
found a way to do it so
what that's going to do is it's going to
give you a position you should be able
to win
and literally force you to do it really
fast and follow your instinct
sounds great to me man maybe i over
hyped it over hyped it your chat is
who the hell is this guy what is this
exercise but i actually think it's going
to be
instructive i believe it i believe it
so okay this guy is like deep in the
tank right now
there i did have one game many years ago
uh and i was mating the guy right and he
was an adult
uh the position on the board was made in
one and he gets up from the board on his
move now in chess tournaments you are
allowed to get up from the board right
you can go to the bathroom
no you don't have people being in their
pants believe it or not
so which surprises people but i'm like
yes they are humane but
explain this guy and checkmating him
okay first order of business find the
fastest checkmate
yeah i'm taking knight d2 with bishop
delivery check
right yeah yeah he takes with a rook and
many ways to mate him yes i'm taking
back with queen
nicely done that's what a thousand looks
like
that's what we do to them this was a
pretty casual one and then
bang yep absolutely so uh as i'm
inviting you to an analysis board
um it was one move away from checkmate
he gets up from the board on his move as
his clock is ticking
and he's got 40 minutes left um and
he goes away from the playing home like
what the hell is this guy doing
comes back 30 minutes later with like a
five guys burger and fries in his hand
yeah well i was like a 12 year old i
wasn't like most confrontational but i
was like
this guy takes literally stalls for 30
minutes on a position with
checkmate on the board waste my time
like all right not cool
but so is that not illegal they didn't
like scolding or anything
the man just went up and got someone
it's his time he
if he wants to freaking go to a
nightclub or
he wants to travel to europe during his
climb he can do whatever the hell he
wants during his clock he can think
about whatever the hell he wants
but it's just funny the length that some
people will come to
um so anyways i have all sorts of
stories about behavior of the chessboard
you will be surprised what chess players
like think of to piss their opponents
off
i think secretly like degenerates like
is there a you know like a crime ring or
something some kind of secret
underground society of chess degenerates
or anything right who think of
progressively more you know nefarious
ways of
[ __ ] with their opponents yeah yeah
that's
that might actually exist and i might
may or may not be a part of it
so really the the only thing so this
development makes sense knight e7
yeah could you tell me one thing let's
let's imagine in the future you castle
do you see a potential future for this
knight on e7
where could it go and what could it
accomplish on that square
well i like to keep the knights towards
the middle of the board since that's
what you taught me at d5 we can get a
nice uh
attack going at least he's going towards
kingside and with where my bishop is and
where my other knight is we can
hopefully look to get something kind of
deep over there on this weak pawn side
per house knight to d5 the only issue
with that move is that the knight is
is basically undefended right it's only
protected by the queen
um which makes the knight a little bit
loose and perhaps subject to move such
as c4
but and this is an idea you're not too
familiar with so i'll sort of tell you
the knight could also come to f5 and
actually take this bishop on g3 and
how do i see this i ask myself which
pieces do i want to trade
and why do i want to trade them right
this bishop on g3 is annoying the hell
out of me because it's pressuring the e5
pawn and that's
i want more freedom in my position i
don't want to keep being saddled by this
so i could take the night with my with
my bishop but
the board is relatively open so i want
to keep my bishops
but this knight could actually take the
bishop on g3
and also ruin the pawn structure around
white's king's side so that would be
kind of a potential idea does that sort
of make sense okay yeah that makes sense
so one thing you want to try to sort of
do regularly
especially in an unfamiliar position to
kind of anchor yourself is
ask yourself what pieces do i want to
trade and how can i accomplish that and
then what pieces do i want to keep on
the board and not trade under any
circumstances for example that would be
this bishop
right okay so just another tool in your
toolkit do you want to hop in for
another one
sure yeah we'll do one more stewart
you're on a roll
jesus these aren't even close
c4 that is the english defense
uh it's just normal development though
right yes yeah i don't need to
okay there there is there are different
moves here but normal development works
and this is a great okay a3
uh so
[Music]
there's no reason to go d4 now right
even though it's there i don't really
want it
right now do it or yeah no
well you do knight d4 oh knight d4 right
he's just gonna chase that knight away
with e3 yeah but yeah so there's no
reason for that right now
he's moving a bunch of his pawns and
when you have a lead in development
remember that you should open up the
center
if possible in order to be able to
explain how can you rip open the center
here
yeah i'm pushing pawn d5 exactly and of
course that's possible two defenders
on the d5 square yeah so this is in
effect a reverse sicilian sicilian is
when one plays e4 black plays c5
um so he's like okay whoa
jesus now he continues to
screw around so you need to take it to
him
yeah i just take this pawn right i'm
just taking c4
uh you could and and open up the
position but actually
i would do something even more ambitious
right um
in addition to taking the pawn you could
just start chasing his pieces away and
make more of a claim in the center
okay so just push the pawn to d4 yeah
and then his knight has no good squares
and you could even take that even
further now you might be like but why
are we closing the center
when i just said to open it it's
obviously not black and
well no pun intended it's not black and
white and you can actually open up the
center again using your other center
pawn what do i mean
i'm just pushing that up at e4 yeah and
you see how
okay so he goes 94 what comes to mind
just taking which i mean that helps open
up the board right sure
and now you can actually open up the
board even further with a move that you
like to play
this is a move i think you you think
about sometimes in your
sleepless nights your the center isn't
quite
enough you know open enough that pawn on
e4 is is
holding you know keeping things a little
bit shut
uh but i i can't attack well i mean i
can attack it by pushing
pawn f5 that's exactly what you should
do what what seems to be
are you hesitant about this move for
some reason i
i i don't know i guess it just didn't
appeal to me opening up your king
yeah it's just i don't know i haven't
canceled long in a while
everything i teach you is basically just
but you're not necessarily going to
castle long you can
absolutely castle short and the fact of
the matter is
uh maybe what worries you you know
you've pushed up upon
in front of the king and castling short
seems risky
guess what look at his development he's
really developed very actively i mean he
is just basically crushing you so he
won't be able to exploit
the weakness of um of your king side
okay so he's got e3
this is a very instructive moment do we
take the pawn
no definitely not we don't want to trade
the queens very good
so we we wanted to keep the tension
yeah so yeah what i was looking at is
bringing bishop c5
so bishop c5 is would have been good had
he not had the move b4
um attacking that bishop forcing that so
this is one of those cases you have two
options you can either
do prophylaxis and prevent b4 and then
develop the bishop to c5
or you could just develop the bishop to
a slightly less
active square but nonetheless a decent
one so can you find one
a move that follows one of these methods
yeah so just pushing pawn a5
that is a very typical move in these
positions preparing bishop c5
the second you said prophylactus i
immediately knew what it does then
well first you you had to change pants
and then you yeah
well that would most gm's are kind of a
low-key obsession with prophylaxis
oh i imagine it's a lovely thing it
really is
you have no idea it's just it's what
people live for
okay so this position is your best to
fall
well he's given you a great opportunity
to expand your claim in the center
um by playing bishop d3
okay he takes with queen actually you
have a really really sexy move here
really sexy and
let me guide you to it okay here's the
thing
he is so undeveloped that in a position
like this you have to smell that there
might be tactics okay
and what does that mean that means you
need to look for checks captures and
threats and you still need to look for
ways to open the center
even if it seems like a blunder so what
move am i talking about what move do you
have to consider
uh a move that looks like a blunder
would be taking the pawn on e3 now why
does it look like a blunder
because i give up a bishop for free look
at that position very very carefully you
see the tension between the queens
yeah you see that you see your pawn on
e3 what can you do to combine that
his queen is defended only by the ten
you you know
tenuously defended by the king so
putting that together yields what move
ah this is after i take on e3 e3 take f5
before i allow you to do it i want you
to find the move in that position
that pawn on e3 is the hint that's the
huge asset you have you can use it
i if that bishop wasn't there i mean the
obvious thing would just be pushing
queen to d2 protected by paul right
but okay so here's the thing is king
defense is queen right
right can you distract his king from the
protection oh i just take
i just hope again it's a check that's
all there is to it
i see
yeah that's a little innocent pawn check
i didn't even think of
and that is actually a kind of thematic
trap distracting the king from its
protection in the queen how do i find
these kinds of things like i said
when you have such a lead in development
and such a superior center
you just have to look for all types of
sacrifices and ways to open up the
center even if it seems not to work you
don't want to rule anything out
right i get you okay that makes sense
so oh i think i just okay we're good
yeah so he's and what happens if he
takes the pawn on e3
then i take the queen it's free uh no i
mean in this position if he takes your
pawn i'm not your bishop
uh then i'm taking his bishop bishop's
protected by queen
exactly so yeah he
he can probably the lesser evil is to
like drop his bishop back to e2 but then
you get like a raging attack on his king
wow there is something like 50 times
sexier than this
that i'm just gonna show you after the
game i don't think it's actually going
to happen
but um okay it actually might but
so continue now he's gonna push his king
up to e2 and
there um
you want to find the fastest path to
victory now start thinking about it what
can you do after king e2
uh then i deliver another check at d4 i
win bishop back
good but far from the best look at your
pawn on f2
remember these positions what three
types of moves do you start with
checks captures threats all of them
so list the captures and consider them
uh taking uh i take queen he takes my
queen he takes my queen with his king
then i get a queen promotion on
bingo and as if insult wasn't you know
as if
and to add insult to injury you win the
bishop too now you had an absolutely
beautiful move
in that position as an alternative that
wasn't as good but i'll show you that
after the game
okay perfect so we get like a queen odds
game basically and
i want you to win this smoothly
okay and my one sort of advice is to
just go after him like just like you did
in that game
don't oh you know just freaking grab the
bull by the horns and
[ __ ] him up yeah i'm gonna do pretty
much the exact same
uh attack path here that i did looking
forward to it
yeah you're just gonna basically take
everything yeah
i'm not even going to risk it not go too
wrong with that yeah
wow but does that whole combination kind
of make okay well he's
yeah yeah he's he's really uh he's
struggling right now
he's exploiting utilizing all the
defensive resources at his disposal
i deliver a check d3 he pushes up to
b2
remember the key concepts of attack in
evolving more pieces when you don't
quite see
checkmate yeah so i'm looking at
bringing my knight to d4
but i don't know if i should do the
check first or bringing my knight in
well you want to do whatever's most
restrictive like whatever
it actually doesn't matter like it's one
of those things we talked about this
when you're
this winning you shouldn't spend time
you should just do what feels right what
your intuition says
and the marginal differences between the
moves just aren't important
that makes sense okay i think
they're actually equivalently good
basically i like windy three check first
oh wait he just checkmated himself
didn't he
i have a check made it so you have a
beautiful checkmate do it quincy too
but it's not checkmate yet because
there's no way of stopping it though
once i uh wait you have a checkmate in
two moves that's
really cool and i want you to find it
it's made in two
four yeah it's the it's the one i'm
looking at right so i'm going knight
before damn okay great you saw it
immediately amazing yeah
it can be hard to [ __ ] is that rokane
seems to be like a dormant volcano like
what is it doing
discover check and mate okay so quickly
to an analysis board
well done okay
all right um so so here here here so d5
the rationale
behind this makes sense right so
dc kind of relinquishes the pressure on
his position although it does
sorry although it does open up the
center um
and i don't know if i'm making sense
here but d4 is just far
more problematic for him
one thing that you could have also done
is just to keep developing we talked
about this the notion of just keeping
the tension so bishop c5 for example
would be good
and you might be like but didn't you say
this is bad because of b4 well in this
position the bishop has an additional
square
that it did not have in the position you
wanted to play bishop so what am i
talking about
d4
one second yeah so d4 is exactly right
pinning his knight
uh okay so so d4 you played knight e4
you took
f5 blasting open the center and i get
your reservations about this move
but sometimes good moves are going to
have drawbacks you know that's
part of what chess is is realizing that
the benefits outweigh the drawbacks and
yes this weakens your king slightly
but that's why a lead in development is
so powerful the person with the lead in
development can basically take all these
liberties
and the opponent can't punish him um
so here here here a5
perfect bishop d3 the other move you
could have played here and i want you to
find it
it's basically a way to keep the fire
churning um and drive
a more of a wedge into the center so i
don't know how to describe this movie
just kind of want you to find it
anything coming to mind
nothing i see it really opens up the
center very much that doesn't
open up the center it uses your central
superiority
and like drives it further into his
grill oh well then yeah just pushing e4
bingo and not only do you pushing for
that might not seem so intimidating but
how do you continue
i'm pushing again to d3 i mean look at
this freaking pawn
look at his knight he cannot develop at
all and then you're just gonna involve
your queen in the attack and just
crash through essentially so
this is the kind of activity that you
when you get more comfortable handling
the center
um you know these moves start coming to
now takes takes
and another question if your king
in this position and let's actually just
do this
would this combination work in this
position
why are why not
does he move his king up on his side
right now he's in check he's in check
white to play and i want you to tell me
if black is still winning
and the way of course to do this is to
think about what has changed as a
consequence of the king's
displacement to e7
uh i see if he brings his bishop my king
and queen are on the same diagonal he'd
win the queen right
right but he's in check right now right
so is that well you're
almost right you have the right idea but
um
the thing is he's either going to lose
his queen or you're going to make a new
one
and i think the reason you you have a
bit of difficulty in these positions
is actually something you could fix you
you try to sort of come up and again i
hate to put words in your mouth but it
seems to me that you're trying to sort
of think your way into the solution and
sometimes you just need to plunge in and
get your hands dirty
and just literally start looking at
moves okay checks capture threats first
you look at the capture
and you play these moves in your mind
and when you visualize the resulting
position it can be easier to find the
move
rather than trying to kind of understand
the logic
through which you can automatically find
the solution without
looking at it do you want playing white
for this right here yeah
yeah white well white to play and your
task is to figure out whether or not
black wins the game here
or when's a queen okay because i had it
on black the whole time and i was
wondering what the [ __ ] changed yeah
sorry i wasn't i wasn't i didn't make it
clear
okay no it's all good okay so my
question is by placing the king on e7
instead of e8 are we actually
changing anything uh for white's
position that doesn't look like anything
changes here there's really not a whole
lot to do if i take the if i take pawn
he takes queen
but look at this position very carefully
uh i deliver the check with the bishop
then i take with rook i see
exactly so the smallest detail
and this is just an important thing to
look for all the time the discoveries
the tension um everything even
stuff that you feel like cannot possibly
work you have to actually go through the
process of looking at it
um if that makes sense mm-hmm okay so
but of course why would the king and up
and e7 in that position it wouldn't just
trying to sort of you know
show you how fragile everything can be
now this is the one position i wanted to
mention had this not existed
you actually had a really really cool
move and the way i'll introduce it to
you've done this once before
here's the sort of strategy right what
we want to do is take the knight
and then we want to fork the bishop with
knight t4 followed by knight takes f5
what's the problem though with taking
and making a queen
why is this actually this actually fails
why
because it doesn't put the king in check
it doesn't put the king of check which
means that white has time for an
intermediate move
um of what kind actually it does
sort of work but nonetheless what
intermediate move does white house
um like he can do something first and
then he can take the queen
uh is it trading queens do we trade the
queens yeah so he can trade queens and
then take on joy now i
i actually just realized that black can
still win the bishop but
you have a really cool move to do the
same thing
but actually delivering a check while
you're at it so what am i talking about
here under promoting
bingo so you can take make a night check
and then
go knight for check and keep the queens
on the board just a little detail to
show
i think you have had like more under
promotions in like a couple months
than i have had in my entire life just
putting it up there
yeah i i can tell you i've done it zero
times
it's it's exceedingly rare so believe it
or not there are even cases where you
have to promote to a bishop and that's
the only win
like all sorts of things exist